this is barn mates and much like this
episode we are on an apology tour yeah
so and I'd like to apologize to
everybody on the planet who I've
offended maybe some people in space I
know there's some people I just
International Space Station um yeah
especially the people from hmm you you
knew you knew you're just a NY that city
yeah um not Jersey actually I'm okay
with Jersey I I root for the underdog so
they're they're good people
unless for the next episode of changes
our mind on that uh which is unlikely
let's just fucking talking about Jersey
again you know the problem with Jersey
oh we've already come through that um
okay so this is another another kind of
bonding episode between we got one
between peridot lapis and she's trying
to do everything she can to kind of be
on her side which I like I like seeing
peridot legitimately trying to win
somebody over when she was the one that
had to be won over before mom and I like
seeing her legitimately trying and lapis
understandably so just say only keep
your distance don't talk to me um and
yeah then you get that big a sigh that
comes in at the end and then you get one
of the little half garnet soldiers with
a ruby eye and it's that goo it's gonna
happen oh that was you I was more like
the fuck I like it when something
legitimately intimidating happens in the
show that I seemed you know legitimately
threatening and I think my favorite
thing in the whole whole episode is when
it was both really intimidating and
really funny is when they build the lake
the tiny little wake and then laughing
has that Nam flashback yeah like that
that is like some PTSD you gonna it was
my tomb what an unbelievable angle and
drawing them I wasn't that coming uh
it's like I mean I both feel bad for but
the same time I was laughing cuz it was
so over the top no it is funny it very
very it was like Principal Skinner like
flashy
back to his days uh you know back in Nam
and I felt the expressions on this one
we're especially good a lot parody now
you wanted her to have mirror eyes yeah
probably that joke definitely one of
work know when he had me rise you needed
to see those people you need was right
school it was right say it say it say it
both agree that's so sad New Jersey
sucked uh there I said it
I'd all learning it that was New York
Center watch like I've been shaving like
all the comments in the last video is
gonna be like New York and New Jersey
like what the hell's wrong with you lay
off them and then like we clearly would
have learned a lesson
no no that's the funny thing whatever I
think is gonna happen does it
you never know it's gonna be New Yorkers
themselves is just like yeah my gosh um
so it's like I can never predict what
the reactions gonna be
you know what I like about the show is
of course it has the action it has the
characters it's got the great artwork I
really liked the way they kind of show
relationships and friendships and stuff
like that uh and it doesn't always work
necessarily kind of the way you'd
predict especially when he's drawing
that line down the middle like don't do
this don't do this and they go and it's
like thank God I'm glad they brought oh
so the scene at the pool was like that
basically that felt good to me because
when she or when Steven drew that line I
turned to you and I'm like she was
trapped in an oceans for months why does
she even need a fucking house you can
look at it you think exposure to the
elements is gonna kill this even where
she was she said she'll yeah she's yeah
it's like what is she well we're in the
barn with peridot and it later it's just
like I was trapped it I was like City
Steven see you see what you're trying to
do what you're doing that um and I like
it isn't necessarily a thing that wins
her over I mean it really kind of looks
like no matter what you know it seems
like it's more just time and her
constantly trying to finally did it
I think paired that about ready to get
blue to
help - well no but I like - that she
respects her wishes when she says what
do you want I'll do it if she says leave
and she goes all that that scene where
she freakin crushes the tape recorder
yeah I got a harsh I'm like oh just cuz
you know how important that thing is to
peridot yeah um so I like but she's also
doing it her own way I love that opening
where she's discussing her plan how
she's gonna win laughs this over right
in front of lapis and she turns uh sis
let's begin like she's just gonna do it
and she clearly hasn't caught on
everything yet uh which I like and I
think it's again especially for a kid
show that sort of makes this kind of
stuff more interesting to teach when
someone has a legit reason for not
catching on to all this stuff um so yeah
trying to think of a kind of thing of
much else I think we have like I mean
the color wise we have red we have green
we have what colors pearl like what
pastel up so sorry we we got it's she's
we have purple we got blue he's through
Easter colors yeah I look at pearl I
think Easter egg I feel like I kind of
have like a lot of the colors into your
now which I really like I think it makes
them very very distinct and stands out
and again you can just look at their
profile you know well you can tell who's
who
burnt sienna uh colors burnt sienna I
guess that's kind of answer mine
it's Sienna that is burn thank you yeah
it's like a like a weird off brown okay
it's a let's go find a box of crayons
yeah
Oh like one of those Family Guy yes oh
so a weird thing for me watching I'm
getting used to it again but watching
the previous episode and now this one
I'm having a little trouble taking
Steven seriously because we met the kid
yeah I just Hades like 18
yeah well that's I know that cell kid
we're all to us that's a kid yeah um but
no but like I thought like maybe he'd be
fourteen thirteen something like that I
gotta get a move next to us as it's a
Kazak something I forget last it was
Callison some cat we didn't have like an
in-depth talk or anything like that but
it sounds like you know me lately
younger sounding boy yeah that's you
know I it was surprising cuz yeah I was
thinking this is like a 10 year old
there's something in it they're like oh
I can't from see when you never see her
you should go say hi alright anyway say
it's like what those things are you want
to shake like a little kids hand like we
were kind of shocked with a he was very
friendly I I'm pretty sure he had no
clue who we were but ya know he had he
did that he did that
nice thing where he's like oh it's great
always to me the family alright or we
can have you know that's always the most
helpful I'm like I I know this stick I
mean it's fine that's the same stick you
know we did the same thing with no I
mean somebody shakes our hand if we
don't know like who they are necessary
yeah so by me like it was really nice it
when you're when you're in a con
situation like that you're always
friendly with you know the other people
in the green room and stuff you mean I
think people forget just how many people
you meet at these conk I mean you just
run all these people and it's like some
you know some you don't I feel bad when
fans or other people who were working at
the con come up like the next year as I
go out we've met I'm like yes yes we did
you're that guy I'm like brutal II
honest when it comes to Adam like I'm
sorry my memory is terrible I just try
to remind me you know if they bring
something up all users if I have a very
vague memory if I could just like just
flash instantly and for a second be like
okay I'll do the half-light thing and be
like oh yeah I remember if I if you're I
did I completely don't remember them
like not even a flash in my hip and keep
it going yeah I'm just like I'm gonna be
honest we meet so many people and we do
so many of these legs is like it's other
Ganci you and most of the time they're
pretty cool with that one time I woke up
in a back alley beaten nearly to death
but like Zak yeah hey kid is Garrett
violent he's got like a right hook it's
just you would if you would not believe
um my board with a nail on it that's his
preferred weapon of choice
y'all don't know that the funny thing is
I thought maybe that would be an issue
but watching it I mean I think cuz the
voice is so distinct I'm just like it's
yeah I mean it's getting better like I'm
getting used to it again but it is
cracking a little I just like weed like
I keep flashing to that guy like and
it's hard to like we did like somebody
like dipper or Mabel like that's there
every yeah like Kristen Schaal or the
guy please said that's their real voice
there's no effect ation really um but
with him me it's so night and day cuz he
just has to normal like wait teens like
18 year old kind of voice yeah and then
I remember we were well like the party
at the green room we're out on the
balcony there at the hotel and we're all
like talking and that's it's like a kind
of a large crowd on this balcony and uh
out of nowhere I just hear Steven
universe's voice like he's doing it for
someone I just like wow this is so
surreal I've got Steven universe behind
we a tremendous day was very nice
yeah but but that's the thing I keep
please real dad nothing I keep flashing
back to just hearing that like normal
guy boys of the house and my guess is so
weird but yeah so that was fun I thought
I would just yeah I share that I guess
and I guess it's a I mean to me it's
really a testament how good you know
some voice actors can be because like I
can just like I said maybe a little I
can hear the cracking voice a little bit
more but it's like I just saw I still
hear he had the panel right before us
and we're waiting for that panel to open
we were like sitting there like come on
Steven just right now uh we were just we
were just waiting for his panel dad and
he did the voice they're like up at the
up at the table like four people died I
yeah I girl there I like Doug and I are
just like City you're watching us with
our jaws when he just unleashes that
little kid voice out over just boom like
we're just like wow because we're can't
saying like I this is him right yeah we
didn't listen
apparently believe in it versus like
maybe this is someone else on the show
like maybe they were just like if he
wasn't so young I would be like well
maybe that Steven universe is dead
obviously that wouldn't work but if you
were like you know 50 years older I've
been like yeah maybe then maybe there's
some little kid wandering of it now he
did it it's an incredible talent IKEA
yeah like affecting a voice like that
well we can make our voices pretty high
but it's obviously a fake voice so he
can kind of like you can tell the voice
but it's still if he sounded like a
little kid he's a good actor um um but
uh yeah I think anything else with this
episode it's gonna go now with that
little half Ruby coming out um what
they're gonna do with that so yeah
that's about it we will see you the next
one later